traveling with the un to bamiyan
it should take just over four hours to
drive to this mountainous province
but the route is far too dangerous now
once seen as the safest place in
afghanistan
recent violence has seen the un
recording over 47
000 internally displaced people in
recent weeks
bamiyan without doubt has one of the
best hospitals in the country
funded by the argo khan
but the hospital has been overwhelmed by
people suffering
after walking for days through the
mountains
i left because the taliban had captured
more districts when we came here all the
people were on the run
they were fleeing my husband works for
the police and wasn't able to come with
us
i took all three of my children to get
some help but i received no help
these are among 300 000 people
displaced across afghanistan since may
the un's humanitarian coordinator
fears if there's no ceasefire things
could get much worse
my fear is unfortunately
is something which gives me trouble to
sleep
i think we will be looking at some of
the worst strategies
which we have seen in the recent history
we traveled in the un convoy out of town
towards the mountains
[Music]
to a school built by the un refugee
agency unhcr
it was constructed to educate children
returning from
outside afghanistan instead these kids
all recently fled their homes
inside the country news of our visit
quickly spread
they thought that the governor is coming
here these women desperate for help
after abandoning their villages
they told us that the taliban are coming
so we fled from our homes
what could we do we were in the baba
mountains and walked all the way
it was freezing there there was no food
so we were obliged to come here
there's a reason people here are so
fearful there's a long history of
persecution
of the hazara the largely sheer ethnic
group that make up most of bamiyan's
population
they remember the taliban's harsh rule
in the 1990s
when they blew up the giant buddha
statues that had stood for centuries in
these sandstone cliffs
the united nations can only provide food
and shelter
when people first flee but we met this
group of families who left their homes
three months ago
and are now struggling all living in two
small rooms
one of the problems is that the un's
humanitarian appeal
is desperately underfunded they've
received just 37 percent
of the 1.1 billion dollars they need
this year
what we've seen here in bamiyan is just
a snapshot
of what's going on in many places in
afghanistan
people on the move fleeing conflict
human misery
that the un is warning could soon turn
into humanitarian catastrophe james
bay's
al-jazeera bamiyan province afghanistan